my wife's had the whole family down the
kitchen table she goes all right i'm
going to vietnam for nine days okay with
my best friend sandy the girls start
unraveling immediately george is like
who are we staying with
my wife's like dad they're like who's
watching us
my wife's like dad they're like who's
watching dad
sounds familiar uh comedian bert
preisher
is a stand-up star with a standout
appearance on stage his shirtless
persona is very familiar to fans and so
is his signature routine his original
facebook post of his stand-up bit
entitled the machine has garnered more
than 40 million views online the youtube
clip has more than 48 million jamie wax
met up with krisher in los angeles jamie
uh with shirt on amy good morning good
morning yes that's right there there is
toplessness in this piece a warning in
the words of the barenaked ladies bert
has a history of taking off his shirt
he's now doing that around the country
on his birdie boy the relapse tour and
he still performs that story just like a
musician giving his fans the hit song
they want to hear and as you'll see he's
evolved while staying authentically
himself
igor looks at me
and in russian he says machine go behind
the bar and grab bread in russian for a
second i'm like i'm learning
comedian bert kreischer is known
internationally as the machine he's like
grabbing the money i'm like
huh and i realized at that instant uh
we're robbing the bar card that's
because of the viral video of his most
famous routine that describes his
experience traveling overseas in college
and accidentally committing a crime with
the russian mafia you're done stand up
and big eager looks at me confused then
smiles takes a big sip of vodka spits in
her eyes and goes no one talks to the
machine like that
and it's a true story right without
embellishment yeah i'm not in trouble
no yeah it's a true story there's
pictures from it i ran into my teacher i
ran into classmates come out that they
were there and i think everyone has
different versions mine's definitely
funnier i think
the people that rob don't have this
isn't as funny as mine
people have been coming to hear him tell
that story for over a decade
this summer kreischer took a roster of
his favorite fellow comics and toured
like rock stars
for his fully loaded comedy festival
stand up selling out a 7 000 10 000 seat
amphitheater which you've been doing on
this tour is almost unheard of i wish i
had a real answer i'm as shocked as you
are last night we were in a 10 000 seat
baseball stadium and it's packed
and i know what it looks like from stage
but then i see an aerial of it and then
we break their ticket sales record my
dad one time got in the shower with me
because i was taking too long and he had
to go to work i was in ninth grade
the stand-up comedian has become a
master of media let's just see how
freaked out he gets when i turn him
upside down
with tv show appearances you can do this
i can do this two podcasts how long do
you think it takes for jennifer aniston
to become attracted to one of us on a
desert island
a while
[Laughter]
massive sold out tours
and popular netflix specials my wife is
brutally honest dude i was getting
undressed in the bedroom the other day
and through the doorway i hear her go
like is that for me and she goes you do
not look good naked like
and all of this success started in 1997
when rolling stone magazine named
kreicher the top partier at the top
party school florida state university i
remember when i read it i'm such a [ __ ]
as i started reading it i was sitting in
my in my living room uh
and in my underwear i just got the
article and i was like uh it took burke
chrysler six and a half years to become
the man he is today the number one party
animal at the number one party school
you wanna know how stupid i am i started
crying i was like that is who i am
[Laughter]
how much did that change your life oh
like
overnight
polarly but
most importantly
i got a few
older men my dad's age my dad included
called me up and they said this is an
opportunity for you if you want to
follow would pursue a dream in comedy or
in
in hollywood this is you're jumping off
and if you don't do something right now
you'll regret it and so it gave me the
bravery i had this article behind me i
had this feeling that like it's already
happening for me let's move to new york
and start a stand-up career the other
day we're in the grocery store right and
i scream out real loud we're in the
produce section i go honey now and
that's exactly what he did
my wife has been with me long enough to
know nothing good is coming after honey
so she plays it off like i don't know
this guy i don't know
you are this authentic very fun very
funny guy
but the art of standup is a whole
different thing yeah did you learn as
you went yeah i learned good things and
bad things so i moved to new york very
quickly my first time on stage i was
really good but i was telling stories
long form stories which is not the style
in new york and so i learned how to
write jokes and tell jokes and i don't
think that was technically technically
my voice but i learned that skill and
and
did that in crowd work and i learned all
that doing stand-up in the in the
village at boston comedy club so this is
home base for you yeah when he's not on
the road he's here at his la home
spending time with his wife and
daughters all of whom are the subject of
a lot of crisis comedy my daughter isla
chrysler
named her period jason
because she got it on friday the 13th
you are a family guy
but you're also the party guy does that
come into conflict at all is having kids
change that for you at all yeah yeah i
remember when i had when i had georgia i
was like i was like
um
not gonna drink i'm done drinking
my daughter will never see me with a
drink in my hand i remember saying that
my wife's like well she can't see
past like six inches
until she's like six months i go okay i
got six months and then next thing you
know you're you're the dad who
is on podcast and drinking and partying
and your kids just get used to it and
it's kind of the only thing they know i
never get out of control i'm just a fun
guy who maybe will say something
inappropriate and probably will wear a
speedo if anything the example i've set
for them is like
have fun party have a great time
but be responsible and bert kreicher
says the party isn't ending anytime soon
do you ever see yourself slowing down no
i'm not going to slow down make hay
while the sun shines that's my motto
if you want to come see me perform i'll
be there if you want to give me a movie
i'll be i will do it this is the best
job in the world like i'm never gonna
stop doing it thank you i will be 75
years old shirtless on stage
and people will be like
oh
he's the machine
i mean come on he is engineered for fun
that guy talk about enjoying life yes
making the most and i will tell you you
know not only is he really hilarious
he's a giant open heart he is the
sweetest guy in the world he seems like
a giant teddy bear the inspiration i
should say for van wylden yeah i would
yeah yeah yeah
he's dan wilder he is van wilder he was
he was the number one partier at florida
state university the number one party
school in 1997 when rolling stone did
that article there's a whole back story
about that but we won't stop great stuff
jamie
[Music]
so give us the back story of mr van wyk
dan wilde well it was his first
hollywood development deal based on the
rolling stone article and one of the
writers took it it fell apart like many
projects do he has never seen the movie
and he's never sued anybody for it
although it is acknowledged it's about
him this is the 2002 movie with ryan
that's correct this launched ryan
reynolds yeah that's how bad hollywood
got it
well it was yeah
but also we talked about that infectious
laugh we have a little a little uh clip
reel that you'll enjoy
when are you cutting it off
[Laughter]
that was my day with bert she reaches
with some of those laughs that's amazing
yes indeed i mean i got to be with him
in mississippi i got to be with him uh
at his home with his family in l.a and
he is just just hilarious i got to
imagine for his daughters i'm thinking
about the joke about the daughter that
named her period jason yes oh my gosh at
what age will those girls
suddenly go it's off limits now no i
don't i think they've grown up with it
it's just like you know growing up with
a
second language in the household
that's weird yeah my children would
never forgive me right can you imagine
the things that you say that they freak
out about already no you embarrass
margot daley